pas une seconde à perdre pour ces
artilleurs
le renseignement militaire vient de
localiser des cibles à l'aide de drones
[Musique]
dans leur ligne de mire des blindés et
des tranchées russes situés en
périphérie ouest de Herson
vladislave commande cette unité il est
chargé d'ajuster les tirs grâce aux
instructions qu'il reçoit en permanence
[Musique]
de la cible pour de l'artillerie et du
bon travail nous avons infligé des
dommages à leur infanterie ils se sont
mis à coudrement on a réussi à les
frapper
cette unité participe à la
contre-offensive vers Herson
l'armée ukrainienne a déployé des
milliers d'hommes pour encercler cette
capitale régionale prise par les Russes
dès le début de la guerre
mais la progression se fait plus
difficile à l'approche de la ville
les artilleurs retournent sur leur base
arrière à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres à l'ouest de Herson il disent
avoir le moral au beau fixe
notre infanterie gagne du terrain maître
par Maître même si le terrain est
difficile nous faisons de notre mieux
pour les aider je pense qu'on ne
s'arrêtera pas à personne et qu'on
reviendra aux frontières de 1991 en
reprenant la Crimée
fait partie du territoire ukrainien
l'armée ukrainienne affiche son
optimisme mais la course contre la
montre continue avec un objectif simple
reprendre personne avant l'hiver